VIDEO OF TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS
BEING MAY. AND IS ALSO TELL OF.
ON MISTER SECTOR CRUISER THE
ROLL. COOLEY HAIR CUNNINGHAM.
SENATE FLOOR YEAH GIPSON HERE
KAMLAGER LATE LEVINE.
MAIENSCHEIN HERE MATHIS RAMOS
YOUR THE APPROVED WHAT YOU'RE-
WE A QUORUM WE HAVE A CORE. AND
HAVE A CONCERN AGENDA- MISTER
FOR YOU WERE. RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST. OTHERS THE CHARGE WILL
BE REMOVED FROM. IS SUCH WILL
BE THE ORDER. IS THERE ARE MY
ON THE OF CONSENT AGENDA. MOVER
MISTER GROUPS SECOND ALBUM
WRONG THIS IS DOCTOR CALL THE.
RAMOS RAMOS HI VIA PULA. THE
FOOD WHILE HIGH SOCIAL CLASSES
HERE TO MOTIONS PASS IS THERE A
MOTION ON ITEM SEVEN. SO
SERVERS ARE GIPSON. SANTA BY
MYSTERON MOST MISTER SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY HI
COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM SENATE
BENNETT HI FLORA. GIPSON
KAMLAGER LI LEVINE LEVINE HIGH
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS RAMOS RAMOS FIVE YEAR
PULA THE APPROVAL HIGH MOTION
PASSES. THE MOTIONS PASSED THIS
RULES PRESERVE DRIVE
COLLEAGUES- JUST REMIND YOU
YOUR COLLEAGUES TO TAKE THE
TEST BEFORE THEY COME UP ON
MONDAY THE REPORT THAT PEOPLE
ARE DOING GREAT BOEING STILL
HELP PEOPLE WITH A LITTLE
REMINDER OF WILL LAND REFER
EARLY. MISTER CLARK. YEAH YES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE ON CONSENT.
BYE BYE LEE HIGH ON HR TWELVE
JONES SAWYER WE HI. OKAY. MIKE
SO WE ARE ADJOURNED THANK YOU.